this comes as a bombshell new article
from The Washington Post is reporting
the US State Department has long been
worried about a research facility in
Wuhan Province in China according to the
post State Department officials in China
quote sent two official warnings back to
Washington about inadequate safety at
the lab which was conducting risky
studies and coronavirus Washington Post
is reporting that to date there is no
firm evidence that the current pandemic
originated in that lab but questions are
mounting here now with the answers that
question and more is Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo yeah I've been reading these
internet rumors ohayo that's a
conspiracy theory made in a lab and I'm
not saying that that's saying that
because I thought SARS was 98% the same
genetic material as of my reading but
I'm beginning to think that something go
crazy here then maybe the the there's
something that we're missing Shan it's
great to be with you here's what we know
here's here's the facts the facts are
you talked about the World Health
Organization they had access the Chinese
Communist Party didn't give Americans
access when we needed in that most
timely point at the very beginning the
president talked about that today and
then we know they have this lab we know
about the wet markets we know that the
virus itself did originate in Wuhan so
all those things come together there's
still a lot we don't know and this is
what the president was talking about
today we we need to know answers to
these things we still have this virus
out there you talked about trying to get
the economy going not only here in the
United States but around the world we
need answers to these questions we need
transparency and we need the World
Health Organization to do its job to
perform its primary function which is to
make sure that the world has accurate
timely effective real information about
what's going on in the global health
space and they didn't get that done here
they only noticed a virus on December
30th last year with pneumonia like
symptoms we only called the corona virus
January 7th first case in the u.s.
January 21st travel ban and the first
quarantine in 50 years in this country
ten days after the first known case in
America now Democrats in the media won't
give this president credit to me it's
incalculable how much
worse this would be how many American
thousands of Americans did not get the
virus and exponentially died why don't
they get the credit that he deserves
that was a gutsy move and he was
brutalized for it Shawn it was a
difficult decision President made the
absolute right call frankly he did it in
the face of a World Health Organization
that suggested that such a restriction
was unnecessary we know that it
benefited the world have benefited
America it's absolutely save lives
you'll recall too that the World Health
Organization declined to call this a
pandemic for an awfully long time
because frankly the Chinese Communist
Party didn't want that to happen we need
a we need a Health Organization's are
going to deliver good outcomes for the
world and not do the bidding of any
single country we need accurate
information transparent information we
didn't get it in the world didn't get
that you know I would like to know you
know when when the head of the World
Health Organization Oh went on the
attack I was like really you failed the
world there was that UK study I'm sure
you saw it 95 percent of this could have
been prevented you said on this show if
you got a call from China you would have
said we'll help you any way we can you
even offer to help Iran because it's
good in the best interest of the world
why didn't they ask for help what is
happening behind the scenes can you
enlighten us you know I I can't answer
the question about the why we also know
about the same time there were those
inside of China medical professionals
there who didn't who tried to tell the
story and were silenced we know that
they've the Chinese Communist Party is
required journalists to leave their what
we need the Chinese say they want
cooperation we want that too but to
cooperate you have to have information
you have to have data you have to have
transparency those are the elements of
cooperation we still want China to do
that we still need information about
what actually took place there we it's
it's not just in the past this continues
and the need for this information
continuously it'll help save lives Sean
and I only have about 40 seconds I heard
when the president decided ten days
after the first coronal case in the u.s.
that there were 20-some up people
talking about the travel ban I hear not
many people agreed with him of any will
you aware of that you know she'll never
talk about internal discussions but I
can say this the press
have made a decision he evaluated all
the facts out there it was a bold
decision the right decision and it saved
American lives the American people ought
to know that I hope that'll get reported
widely I just gave you a chance to tell
the story and break news you didn't do
it let you would number one at where you
went to West Point last time I think I
said you went somewhere else I apologize
for you a number one in your class
attention that's very kind thank you all
right thanks for all you do we
appreciate it